[музика]
як правило моєї ці подорожі
продовжуються метрів на 200 вперед там
де нещодавно зробили спуск
Ось такі забіги з перепонами Сергій
храбко долає щодня виїжджаючи з дому на
своєму танчику як він називається свій
електричний інвалідний візок
Голосіївський район де мешкає Сергій
відносно новий але за кожне рішення щодо
безбар'єрності йому доводилося боротися
по-перше роки самостійно я не виїжджав
взагалі
не роки напевно рік Можливо
тому що ну переповнено кожному кроці це
якби не дивно було ні для кого й раніше
і зараз тим більше
самостійно пересування особливо без
електровізка воно дуже
як мінімум важко це все максимум то
іноді і небезпечно Сергій Ветеран АТО у
2015 році він брав участь у боях на
світлодарській дузі де потрапив під
мінометний обстріл у результаті чоловік
втратив лівій руку і ногу через
повномасштабне вторгнення Росії людей з
інвалідністю в Україні стає дедалі
більше тому переконаний Сергій міський
простори мають активніше враховувати
їхні потреби треба розуміти цивільних
багато військових забагато дуже багато
ампутації дуже багато рук ніг
різного ступені складності і запит
величезний
це ну
раніше було це не просто
Зараз я собі взагалі не уявляю як це
бути вже відбуватися
на запит ДВ у КМДА відповіли що при
інклюзивність пам'ятають і роблять що
можуть відповідно до наявного
фінансування наприклад зазначається що
Київський комунальники вживають заходи
щодо пониження бортового каменю на
наземних пішохідних переходах депутатка
Київської міської ради Ксенія Семенова
подала на розгляд проєкт який має
зобов'язати КМДА пришвидшити роботу над
безбар'єрним середовищем зміниться
керівник наприклад і Ну десь повинно
повинно таке політичне рішення міста що
ми цим займаємось Що ми робимо наземній
пішохідні переходи воно десь повинно
бути зафіксовано депутатка зокрема
пропонує дублювати підземні і надземні
переходи наземними Це допомогло би
маломобільним людям переходити дорогу не
використовуючи сходи на думку Сергія
храпка саме високі бордюри І відсутність
пандусів це основні перепони в місті за
його словами у Києві досі багато
громадських місць абсолютно не
зафіксованих до потреб людей з
інвалідністю парк Рильського там одні
запитання там відповіді нема взагалі там
просто людині на візку взагалі Ну
апріорі неможливо подолати його
нівздовжніх поперек ніяким чином взагалі
там є невеличкі
нюанси де місцями щось там робилося в
минулому році там але це точечно якось
експерт з планування міського простору
Тимофій Нагорний вже давно займається
питанням безбар'єрності Києва на думку
урбаніста такі речі треба одразу
закладати в проєкти планування бо
виправити Те що вже збудовано складніше
і дорожче
і Саме цей перехід він будувався тоді
коли прокладалася вулиця Павла
Скоропадського 2001 рік тоді ніхто не
думав ні про жодну інклюзивність коли
будувався цей Бесарабський квартал тому
тут такий рельєф Саме тут що тут дуже
складно впровадити наземний пішохідний
перехід до початку заходів з
інклюзивності На порядку денному КМДА
також громадські транспорт у мерії
звітують станом на грудень 2021 року на
балансі підприємства перебуває 61
автобус 357 тролейбусів 100 трамвайних
вагонів які повноцінно пристосовані для
перевезення осіб з інвалідністю проте за
словами Сергія на практиці такі
транспорт функціонує не так як хотілося
б Я безмежно щасливий що в нас є
автобуси наприклад з низькою платформою
але я був би ще б щасливіший якби вони
працювали як правило там чи не працює ця
відкидна штука чи там не знаю у водія
болять руки там ну там куча відмазок
буває але як правило маючи автобуси на
сьогоднішній день з відкидною платформою
ти не завжди маєш змогу заїхати в нього
на думку Сергія єдиний вид транспорту
який відносно непогано адаптовано до
потреб маломобільних людей це метро там
людям на візках допомагають
співробітники щоправда за даними самої
шкмда з 52 столичних станцій метро лише
13 повністю пристосовані для пересування
осіб з інвалідністю та інших
маломобільних груп населення на думку
урбаніста Тимофія нагірного столиці
України все ще не можна назвати
комфортною для маломобільних людей
невеликі зрушення є але щоб відчутно
поліпшити ситуацію необхідні системні а
не точкові рішення треба просто не
боятися їх впроваджувати в першу чергу
це кому треба робити міський владі
активісти підкажуть але активісти не
можуть самі зробити і активісти не є
проектантами вони не є управлінців
депутатка Ксенія семенева погоджується
що на КМДА має тиснути громадське
суспільство а депутати Київради мають
подаватись затверджувати більше проєктів
щодо інклюзивності
столиці продемонструє бюджет на
наступний рік складне питання із
бюджетування тобто на етапі розподілу
бюджету на наступний рік це повинно
обов'язково з'явитися і я буду це для
себе розуміти як індикатор успіху цієї
затії взагалі тому що вирішити що дада
ми дублюємо підземні переходи наземними
можна але далі питання Скільки таких
дубльованих переходів закладеться в
бюджет на наступний рік і це те що вже
до нового року Київрада буде голосувати
бюджет на наступний рік попри всі
складнощі з якими стикається Сергій він
не хоче відчувати себе жертвою обставин
чоловік займається спортом водить дітей
до школи працює на думку військового
проблеми маломобільних людей стосуються
всіх киян а не лише людей з інвалідністю
Я вважаю що це не стосується
безпосередньо ветеранів Як таких або
людей
інвалідів Я маю на увазі іменно саме
військових для цього Великого розуму не
треба люди з в дитячому не можу
піднятися от в чому питання умовно
кажучи це як нам в першу чергу образа
людей в цілому має бути тому що не може
підняти ногу бо бабця в 70 років на ту
сходинку Ну то яка різниця хто на неї
піднімає ногу Ветеран чи бабця Ну за
словами урбаністів в інших українських
містах особливо маленьких ситуація з
безбар'єрністю та інклюзією ще гірше і
завдання держави подбати щоб людина з
обмеженнями у пересуванні цих обмежень
не відчувала